also schreibe ich schon richtig lecker
an so nehmen wir mal einen ganzen ganz
kleines stück überhaupt der zunge
zergehen lassen können
oh ja drauf gewisse leute was geht ab
ich hoffe euch geht's gut
licht in ordnung kann man damit arbeiten
du bist ein komischer keinen moment mehr
zeit aufgefallen ich sehe so brase aus
deswegen hab ich mir jetzt hier mal
diese jacke rausgekramt wer jetzt sieht
sie auf jeden fall als sie aus das ist
gut passt auch zu mir ja potsdam für die
das video gestern nicht gesehen haben
ich habe jetzt vor alle sachen die bei
videos über bleiben wie zum beispiel
gestern hatten wir ein beamer und so
musik dinger immer meine instagram sorry
zu posten da könnt ihr dann darauf
antworten und dann verlose ich dir an
irgendwen allen darauf antwortet weil
das viel einfacher ist jetzt über
youtube die person dann erstmal
ausfindig zu machen dauert ewig deswegen
folgt mir sehr gerne auf instagram 30
alex wie und airports haben in köln
jetzt starten aber auch endlich mit dem
heutigen video ich glaube ich habe noch
gar keine begrüßung macht deswegen
eheleute was darf ich hoffen natürlich
geht es gut mir auch danke und zwar habe
ich vor dem geraumen zeitraum ein video
gemacht und die zwei videos sogar da
habe ich es ins neuheiten getestet wir
hatten sogar auf pizza neuheiten und all
so was und das habe ich jetzt länger
nicht mehr gemacht ich habe eine seite
gefunden auf instagram die ländliche new
germany eigentlich eine weiße seite der
folglich auch schon ein bisschen länger
und da habe ich jetzt in letzter zeit
öfter mal ein screenshot gemacht wenn
irgendwas neues herausgekommen ist und
ich das gefeiert hat und ich war heute
einkaufen und habe ganz viele neue
produkte die im letzten monat also im
august von september auf den markt
kommen sind irgendwelche süßigkeit oder
sonstiges gekauft man muss jetzt leider
sagen ich war so ewig unterwegs sollte
ich habe mich so tod gesucht einfach
weil ich alles was ich so gerne hätte
habe ich nicht gefunden
das einzige was ich wirklich unbedingt
haben wollte war dieses red bull winter
edition spekulatius dinger wieder
skeptisch ich will es gar nicht wissen
und was auch ganz cool war diese
snickers hier sind jetzt wohl obwohl die
sind so hat mir der typ das erklärt die
sind noch gar nicht auf dem markt
gekommen allerdings jetzt mal raus und
er stand an
landtag und hat halt immer so paal
probier stücke aufgeteilt so und da habe
ich dir gleich mal mitgenommen weil es
passt auch zum thema wir machen es wie
immer ich wäre das jetzt gleich
probieren vorteil wieder eine punktzahl
von eins bis zehn
schauen sie das juli heute nicht in der
kamera ist ich weiß mit kameramann ist
entspannter wir starten einfach mal
womit starten was ich hier ja solar
skittles skills smoothies sind aber
eigentlich schon mal ganz lecker aus
deswegen ja wir haben ja blau gelb und
pink
ich muss jetzt schon nämlich leider
sagen wenn sie diese normalen skittles
feiere ich nicht sprechen nicht klagen
ich meine warum aber die sind deutlich
besser schmecken richtig gut so ein ganz
kleines bisschen milch eben wie ich weiß
nicht das ist schwierig zu erklären also
die kann ich auf jeden fall richtig
empfehlen ich teile hier einfach mal
neun von zehn punkte aus geil überzeugt
mich was ich auch super interessant fand
guck mal hier hanuta cookies ich werde
euch auch hier mal den post von der
seite einbinden
wo ich diese ganzen sachen her habt
damit ihr das auch sehen können dass das
wirklich neues handelt habe ich früher
sehr gerne gegessen
deswegen bin ich jetzt mal gespannt
cookies alles klar also da ist halt
einfach anscheinend eine andere füllung
wenn ich jetzt mal hier zwischen da gibt
es einen einfachen trick wie man die
hunters aufmacht und da geht nicht so
wie ich es gemacht habe
richter auf jeden fall brutal gut
keynote war mein gott da ist erinnert
mich so hart an dieser hypo dinger kennt
ihr das
das schmeckt sogar müssen wir gar nicht
lange rum la zehn von zehn auf jeden
fall lässt sich gleich noch weiter alle
die sich fragen warum ich gerade gerufen
habe vielleicht ist es auch nicht so die
beste idee von mir genau jetzt dieses
video zu drehen weil ich war heute
morgen beim zahnarzt und habe so eine
kleine füllung bekommen meine zähne sind
eigentlich top ich habe mir auch echt
gewundert warum das bei mir nötig ist
und da wird dann zahlen so ein bisschen
rum gespielt und drohende bröckl und ich
habe auf jeden fall schmerzen nicht
darauf weist ein bisschen aber gut jetzt
stellt sich die frage wo mitmachen
arbeiter red bull kommt auf jeden fall
noch nicht dass wir hier mit
weitermachen
leibnitz keksen queen eigentlich hatte
ich vor leibnitz ich weiß nicht da gibt
es noch etwas neues mit pinken übergröße
die wollte ich haben habe ich in zwei
supermärkten nicht gefunden in riesen
supermärkten
da hab ich gesagt weißt du was die hier
sind auch herausgekommen ist zwar ist es
schon monat länger her
aber dann habe ich mir diese mitgenommen
aber auch hier finde ich sieht
eigentlich lies ausrichter auch gut ist
wahrscheinlich wieder irgendeine obere
kooperation da die machen ja nicht alles
gold ist was schmeckt ähnlich wie loriot
auf jeden fall auch nice kommt
allerdings um längen nicht an dieses
heran
deswegen gibt es von mir hier sieben von
zehn aber nicht schon okay womit
manchmal weiter dass wir hier mit
weitermachen
auch neu milka zarte momente ganz zart
im moment ist guck mal hier kooperation
mit orion
wobei ich glaube dass opel und milka
unter einer decke steckt ist das gleiche
unternehmen bin ich mir relativ sicher
weil so viele kooperationen wie die mit
einer haben hatte ich nicht in meiner
ganzen youtube karriere mit
irgendwelchen anderen unternehmen so
eigentlich schade
deswegen hier nur kooperationspartner
sucht dann meldet euch einfach mal so
man muss aber sagen so an den
verpackungen hier finde ich alle die
lassen sich alle was einfallen und das
ganz entspannt zu öffnen auch hier alles
noch mal extra eingepackt ist das gut
für die umwelt er nicht habe aber ist
wahrscheinlich vorschrift ja alle leute
let's try auf jeden fall auch nice wir
hatten noch nichts wo ich gesagt habe
schmeckt mir überhaupt nicht allerdings
muss ich sagen das ist auf der einen
seite natürlich auch schlau dass sie
ihre produktbreite immer weiter
vergrössern also es ist immer mehr
produkte gibt die sich ähneln oder die
man unter die gleiche kategorie fassen
kann sagen was man so allerdings ist das
absolut kein neuer geschmack für mich
das gibt schon so oft in so vielen
verschiedenen formen
deswegen muss ich dir sagen ein bisschen
unnötig aber wenn wir jetzt mal nur den
geschmack bewährten schmeckt wirklich
gut acht von zehn punkte warum man nicht
so sein so
euro leute ich bin so gespannt geht dass
man hier ein bisschen randers faktisch
so ab dass ich keine kamera mit mir
dabei hab juli hier red bull für dich
winter edition spekulatius das wäre doch
was für dich oder machen wir das mal auf
das ist mir eben im auto das ganze auto
gerutscht war eine vollbremsung einlegen
musste ich hoffe es sprudelt nicht zu
sehen
das wird ja jetzt riecht noch mal ran
ganz interessant ganz interessanter
geruch bevor wir das jetzt allerdings
probieren habe ich noch hier von duplo
was gefunden und zwar habe ich extra
gefragt das ist wohl auch neu ist auch
eine limited edition extrafilm winter
duplo weit winter mandeln also das halte
ich schon richtig lecker an so dem
normalen ganz ein ganz kleines stück es
war auf der zunge zergehen lassen können
auf gewissen meiner meinung nach
tausendmal geiler als originale duplo
das kann aber auch daran liegen das habe
ich früher so oft gegessen wenn ich
jetzt es mir fast schlecht davon
das hat dann auch so seine gründe auf
jeden fall mégane eis da muss ich
wirklich sagen auch zehn von zehn kann
man hier so ein bisschen mit diesem
handwerk ups vergleichen könnt euch mal
und dann stinkt mir ein foto bei
instagram da freue ich mich mal richtig
wenn leute joecks hier aber auf deine
empfehlung mal probiert schmeckt geil
manche schreiben schmeckt nicht sogar
manchmal passt sich das dann auch meiner
in story
deswegen lohnt es sich locken aber ins
dazu folgen und wir trinken jetzt direkt
man hinterher red bull spekulations
winter edition also was da jetzt dass
spekulatius schmecken soll verstehe ich
es riecht ein bisschen nach spekulatius
es schmeckt aber eigentlich nur wie
gummibärchen in flüssig weil ich gar
nicht tut mir leid also da ist mir das
normale red bull schon lieber schade
eigentlich
also der geruch ist echt gut der
geschmack nicht so besser wenn es
andersrum wäre natürlich ne naja dann
muss ich dieses jahr weihnachten wollen
doch wieder glühwein trinken
red bull spekulatius mit ein bisschen
alkohol bei ihm war vielleicht sollte
man das mal ausprobieren guter rahmen ob
der zwei sachen sogar wobei das direkten
ein geschoss nicas christ und hat dann
gleich zwei reden
zwei kleine riegel in einer verpackt ich
hab das eben schon probiert der typ hat
mir so ein kleines probier stück gegeben
und ich muss sagen dass man es ist
einfach noch mal probieren so sieht es
übrigens von innen aus wollt ihr das
erkennen könnt also es ist auf jeden
fall auch nicht schlecht eigentlich
schade dass ich nix hatte wo ich die
sagen kann absolut scheiße kauft es
niemals aber das ist jetzt auch nichts
wo ich sagen kann wie zum beispiel hier
bei diesem hanuta cookies oder duplo
winter wandel das ist mich richtig
umhaut deswegen kann ich hier leider
auch nur acht von zehn punkte geben was
natürlich trotzdem gut ist aber da fehlt
irgendwas ich weiß nicht was das
heftigste haben wir fast noch besser als
das toplos aber maintal leute so viel
erstmal dazu eine sache habe ich noch
wobei ich glaube ich dieses ding schon
mal probiert
ritter sport mangel orange ich war mir
nicht sicher dass habe ich direkt am
anfang mehr mitgenommen jetzt auch
erstmal egal wenn gesagt mach mal dieses
format in diese richtung öfter dass
sicherheit immer bei dieser seite gucke
was neues und das dann vorstellen
nächstes mal dann auf jeden fall auch
noch ein bisschen auf professioneller
und so gibt dem video daumen nach oben
aber in den kanal glocke aktivieren wir
sehen uns morgen 19 uhr wieder haut rein
privatem 1.20 uhr sorry